foreign
one of the things that people's been
been struggling with is telling
themselves no and that was kind of the
purpose of doing this right so that we
would all get in the habit of telling
ourselves no but it's been pretty cool
on Instagram having some pretty deep DMS
with people where they're like man I I
fell into temptation again I just didn't
tell myself no how do I get to where I
tell myself no so somebody sent me
something on Instagram that I thought
was pretty cool my husband went and
hunted it down and it's called the just
say no button and it's kind of you know
so many people listen to the show to
have you kick their booties into shape
and to tell them no and I found this
little button no and it's like sounds
like a cow
it's like people can have you in their
pockets
do it again so if you're walking around
through life and you're like on baby
step one and you're thinking should I go
out to eat tonight
[Laughter]
should I buy this random kitchen gadget
on Amazon
is my last word no
[Music]
we need to get this remade with my voice
and we can sell a bunch of them I said
no right it sounds almost like you
should we go on vacation and baby step
two
[Laughter]
should I lend money to my family no
no should I use my credit card if I'll
pay it off each month
where did you get this it's Gotta you
gotta you're like Amazon right or
whatever actually you didn't say no you
bought the no button we found it at
Target oh so great we were also thinking
like maybe it could be like one of those
like game show buzzers especially when
you're not in town if a caller calls in
and they're like so I know you normally
don't recommend car loans but in my
situation bam no means no
oh this is so great well our audio guys
really ought to be able to reprogram
that with our voices like Jade and me
and you you know that Rachel Cruz going
well now I think the tribe would love it
it would help people say no it would be
so funny no is a secret weapon really
we're gonna do a whole month of this or
you're just gonna sell these buttons
probably just sell these you're not even
selling them we don't even have them I
think we need a Dave button like this
it's kind of a pitch for you Dave we
could even like put it in the every
dollar app
or maybe attach it to the Rachel Cruise
wallet you know we could just instead of
selling it we could just make an app and
there we gotta be free and just let
people get the app button no
no it's a complete sentence
you're ready to go
just the uh it's the ancient word that
no one hears in America
and uh it gives you great power when you
can say this it's you push the root your
tongue towards the roof of your mouth
[Laughter]
you release Air and you say no you're
really good at saying it Dave I think we
could equip the tribe I'm really good at
this I have a I have a spiritual gift of
no the spiritual gift of no and hey you
know what you say no so you can say yes
later and Dave will help you with it
yeah you say yeah that's exactly the
only reason I did say no ever so just so
I can say yes later more generosity more
enjoyment
more blessings uh and they only come if
you say no now just live like no one
else so that later you can live like no
one else and you need a no button to do
that I'm afraid we just sold 10 million
of them for Target but oh well I wasn't
going to mention whether it's just that
true story
it's a red button somebody had the easy
button it was like Staples right they
have the easy button and this is the
opposite yeah we need to take no button
this is the hard button but this one
actually works and this hard button pays
off this is how you get wealthy so
you're just going to use this on your
Instagram DMS now
anybody who reaches out and they're just
struggling then I'll just be like no no
no no
or if me and Rachel are on air and we're
having a hard time being as raw as we
need to be no no that one sounds like a
cow
there we go we got to get the aggressive
one ready you gotta get the cow out
there then no that one's bad I don't
like that one but the rest of them are
fabulous that's so good everybody should
have one in their pocket if you ever
need a good hard no if you need to all
the Spenders out there that are
struggling to keep their budget in check
this is for you this is for me this is
for Rachel this is for all of us who
need to hear a good this is my last word
no
foreign